Oh we're going to die
i'll be back
[Plastic bag crinkling]
[Suspenseful music]
Hey, how's it going?
what're you doing here?
Ok, ok, alright anyways so
look around the van
Do you see anything suspicious here?
Something that might be missing
untapped potential, yeah
So when I look around this van
I don't see
failed plans like
"oH tHE- tHe VAn dOeSN't hAVe eNoUgH poWeR fOr a FRidGe!"
no
I see more opportunity than we ever let on before
Isn't that right bubba?
Where's my whiteboard?
thank you, thank you, thank you
just give it a good smell
I mean look over the smell of the rotting pumpkins
and the guava
cause I'm thinking, BAM!
haunted house
Oh yeah, that's right
when you see stores like this
they're basically pop up shops
pop up shops are all the rage
there's tons of clothing stores that are just pop up shops
and they come and go, and then they're gone
people love it, because they love the rarity of it
so we dressed this place up to the teeth
we already got the jack o lanterns
we already got the broken tv
we already got the non-existent fridge
we already got all the terrifying peepo over here
and then
we can have the most successful haunted house in all of Los Angeles
how bout that
all right. let's go to work so what do I have
I've got scary lights
power, doodly doo
oh yeah don't help me or anything
come on open this stuff up, ohh ohh hahh
these'll be here
that's good. AHH!
we've also got wall decorations
for all blood
we've got various slogans such as
keep out
which should be ridiculous cause they're already in
so it's like
shouldn't've walked in here
let me see if I can slap this bad boy. Ahhhh!
keep
where's out go?
out
nice
so deadly
watch this shit
Oh oh oh oh oh, hahahah
maybe
up up up ahh
I also forgot the impossible costume
i got you a ghoul
I got you sexy chucky
which would you rather have?
I got an inflatable skellington
yeah I gotta get this
alright you keep working on that I'm going to blow
a wise man once told me
if you had one shot
one opportunity
would you take it?
or would you blow?
*mark blows for real*
oh that's a scary man
UHH ER GUHHHOOOHH
We gotta squeeze him real good right in the
you gotta grab him by the bruh
you gotta give him a good uh
he's dying
clear
*grunts
that might be the scariest thing I've ever seen
nice
switch spots I need more room to blow
I gotta be on the bed to blow
yeahhh
WOOHHAHHOOAWAHH
come with me
we need to let people know on the outside
that this van's the real deal
so just to add on to the sticker legacy of this van
I think it's only appropriate
boo
terrifying
thanks for getting a hair in there
so what else we looking at?
possibly the scariest thing I've ever seen: Stanley
you'll believe me when i say it
Hi, I'm Stanley
I'm going to murder you now
shut that door and let's get to killing
let's just
whatever
shoo-ba-dee-
ah-ha!
joke's on you
oh! spooky.
we'll just set that right
right by the keep out
like just to illuminate
so people know safety regulations
say that you need to like
let people know about your
their imminent death and mistake
don't do it don't!
keep out
listen to the sign
it's very clearly there
for your protection
alright ok
so we got Stanley
we got the keep out we got the strobe
we got your werewolf hands
we got a lot of murder weapons
we'll clean this up later
we got a disembodied hand
you should totally do a trick where you're just like
woah
you know like that but better than I did
oh we got spooky skulls and glow sticks, but we'll bust those out when we get started
sound cool sound fun?
let's get to spooking some people.
Mark: We're not open yet
Tyler: Boo eek?
M: no you don't say it we're not open
err take Chica for a walk
take her potty. we're not ready yet
Tyler: Ok pull up there
M: no
T: fine
It's a start up
we need a little more time.
T: OK
M: It's better to be late and good
than early and not good
M: cause then people T: I actually agree with that sentiment.
M: there we go then get out
we're are ill-prepared for this. launch day is so scary
well get in and help
oh the spider web. how can you forget the spider web
idiot
crack open one of these bad boys
yellow is the scariest colour
as we all know
gotta duck underneath the yellow urgh
oww
do you have a screwdriver
make a friend?
she had a good poop
oh jesus
I watched you do that and I still kept looking
its not even
I've fixed it by breaking it
*very spoopy laughter*
pretty spooky right
don't get too scared
get a good shot of his reaction
first sale I got it
what an idiot
enjoy your stay
bonjour good luck
oh jeez
It smells very pine-y in here
uh
*laughter*
nice and bouncy
its an earthquake zone here
in the haunted van
I wonder who's foot this is
howling
oh my gosh
scary dude nice pumpkin
what is the smell
the smell its like pine tar
pine glue, lemons?
the smell is lemons
Your time's up any additional time will be an extra $20
I don't have anymore...
Get out!
Oh.. Fine! Jeez..
So uh... Please rate on Yelp what you thought
If you had to give a review
of the haunted house
I mean 1 star cause you can't really move but,
One star?
I'd give it two for the shaking
Just the sha....
Alright, so we've found a park
we've got everything ready to go
Tyler's gonna get in costume soon
but then I'm going to send out a tweet here
"Come see the world's first pop up haunted house,
look for the van in Palms Park on Overland Avenue"
and bingo bongo it's there to go
We'll do it like drug dealer style
We'll just get the first few people in for free
get 'em hooked on the experience
and then they'll keep coming back for more. Right?
there's no way we can lose
here's how it's gonna be:
you are going to be inside
and you're going to be the second scarer
you're gonna you're gonna like mislead them
they're going to come in though the passenger door
you are going to be here posted up
and your gonna be like "I'm scary! I'm scary~!"
just when they least suspect it Tyler's going to pop up in the driver side window
just boo!
and really give them the first spook
you're then going to move backwards into your spot in the corner
and uh film their reaction so we can really see it in good glorious HD
and then at the end once they had their fill they'll come out this way
Bob's your uncle they'll be done
meanwhile after I get them in I'll shake the van.
sound good? ok. we got a plan.
you look very spooky, take that off before someone calls the cops
We got a paying customer here. By the way this costs money.
Customer: oh jeez. Mark: Hope you brought your wallet.
*vague howling sounds, banging, erm*
You got me in the van, that's more than I can say for my intelligence.
*muffled* I am a zombieeeee
*Customer laughs*
Your time is up, I hope you've had a satisfying terrifying experience.
I want a refund
Why?!
you didn't pay any money for it
I still want something back.
We got our second customer. Are you ready? Ok. All right.
Hey! Welcome welcome welcome
*door slams*
Wah okay! Haha.
Oh NOOO. So is this like an escape room type deal? Like am I supposed to figure something out?
*spooky voice says NO*
Mark: all right your time's up. Customer: Oh OK.
Did you make it out alive?
Uh... technically I did.
Okay good job congratulations!
If you had to rate it like one out of like ten
Maybe either like a two and a half or like a twelve uhh both sides of the spectrum
That doesn't make any sense
This is what death looks like Isn't it?
Mark: Oh boo a foot! [customer gasps]
Mark: Wuh!
*customer laughs at noises* Bwooooh!!!!!! Mwahahahahah!!!!
Oh no... Haha!
*more spoopy noises*
Look out for Stanley!
He's very scary
All right time's up. Did you have fun?
I did!
Goooood~!
That was the best haunted house I've been to this year.
Have you been to any?
No
Well. Alright then,
You're up next. It's going pretty well so far I'd say.
Uh, I'd say our average score is probably around
*wolves howl*
shut up! shut up you!
Probably around a 6.5, maybe a 6.7
Which, I think is pretty good for a mobile pop up
Uh, haunted house
Like, the best we can hope for
BWAAA!!
Customor: Oh shi-
Tyler: Hey!
Mark: You'll never escape~!
You'll never, EVER, escape!
Alright that's it you made it.
You made it out.
If you had to rate it out of one out of ten,
Mark: OOOOWWW!!!
That's the highest score we've had!!
Thank you!
*spoopy noises and faint laughing from customers*
AAAAHHH!!
Customer 1: *laughs* Uh....
Tyler: SCARY GHOST!
Customer 1: What am I looking-
Customer 2: What am I supposed to do?
*both laugh*
Mark: Alright everyone! Watch out for Stanley!!
Customer 1: Is it in the refrigerator?
*banging noises*
Customer 2: The fridge is shut...
Customer 1: Oh! Is that you?!
ook... OH!! It's you hello
Jeeez!
Mark: What are you going to doooo~? how are we going to surviveeeeee~?
I found a clue!
Oh! We are going to die.
Mark: Times up.
Ahhhh ripppp
I was like I cant see anything in here
If you had to rate it 1-10
I'd give it a solid 14
Awwwww
That bring the average way up!
Yeahhhh. That's very convenient
You found- you found the mini fridge, I see
We did, yeah. There was someone named Iliana that was real nice about this and actually gave it to us herself.
Oh do you want to sign the-the van?
I would love to sign the van
HIYAH
Alright, so we're finally done with that
Not bad for a first day in a haunted house
I'd say if I learned anything from the experience
maybe don't make a creepy white van creepier by parking it in the middle of the woods
and putting a haunted house in it
BUT
Nonetheless, it was a good experience and it was a lot of fun.
Everybody that came by was super sweet
Everybody that we met was just awesome
And, uh
I love doing these things, and I especially love doing these things with you, so
Thanks for being here for me
And, uh
As always, I'll see you in the next video
BUH BYE